I'm sorry, Lisa.
I am pumped about protecting abortion.
It's the economy I really care about.
And Trump, he's keeping this economy yoked.
But you do realize that abortion is an economic issue.
I thought abortion was just about, like,
morals and feelings and stuff.
Well, when women are denied access to abortion,
that affects their ability to work,
to finish school, to earn money.
And banning abortion slows down the economy.
I want the house of Congress to be a house of gains.
When women have access to abortion,
they can decide to have kids,
which means that they are more likely to finish their education
and get better jobs. That means that they make more money,
which boost the economy. OK,
no offense, Lindsay,
but I'm no soy boy. This is just about women,
not about me. Being forced into parenthood early hurts men's wallets,
too. Studies estimate that abortion restrictions cost the US economy
$173 billion a year. Wait,
billion?
Like with a B? It's all connected, Kevin.
Economic mobility is like a protein shake.
If you don't get the nutrients that you need,
you can stay strong. And with strict abortion bans,
neither can the economy. So abortion access isn't the way
protein of the economy,
sure.